big headline from the conservative
manifesto 50,000 more nurses on our
overstretched hospital wards bursaries
for nurse training will be brought back
but the funding for it has already been
questioned and one of the things that we
can do with this new package is not just
have the bursaries for nurses and people
who want to become nurses but also have
the place is the training places in
universities and hospitals and the
apprenticeships that we want to use to
recruit so it's more than just the
bursary it's also about having those
training places available opposition
parties claim the numbers don't add up
Labor's shadow health secretary Jonathan
Ashworth says the pledge is frankly
deceitful and the Lib Dems Luciana
Berger called the figures insulting to
the public so what's the argument about
of the fifty thousand promised nurses
fourteen thousand will be new graduates
and undergraduates coming into the
system grants for trainee nurses which
was scrapped in 2017 by the
Conservatives will be partially
reinstated a u-turn by the government
after the move led to a drop in nursing
applications but their tuition fees are
not all covered a further 12 and a half
thousand nurses will be recruited from
abroad through a new NHS visa and it's
hoped that around a third of the total
eighteen and a half thousand will be
existing nurses either staying in the
profession or returning to it because of
improved career opportunities a few
years ago the current government removed
the nursing bursary which meant we saw a
really significant decrease in the
number of applicants coming into nursing
what they pledged that they're making
for should they get into government's
next time it goes some way to replacing
half of what they took away and those
criticisms were quickly jumped on by the
opposition who say new nurses will have
to be found elsewhere
well since they're a party that's
presided over 40,000 nurse vacancies in
the NHS who three years ago said there
was going to put more doctors in the NHS
and there are now six thousand five
hundred less doctors or vacancies of
doctors in the NHS they haven't put the
money into nurse bursaries they haven't
put the money into education and
training they are simply proved they're
unable to do it
Forrest Johnson was all smiles as he
launched his manifesto claiming
delivering brexit would allow the
government to focus on public services
like the NHS but can big figure promises
translate into action
[Applause]